49 King seconds of logos opening a movie
with a close-up of an eye cliche
see also Apollo 13 contact lost Star
Trek first contact and even Ridley
Scott's own Blade Runner I am your
father
I assume Ridley Scott created this
flashback scene as an apology to Guy
Pearce for all that old man makeup he
had to wear in prometheus why are the
statues head and feet obscured it's
either poor planning or the design over
the room really wanted the focus to be
on David's marbled marbles not selection
dealer's choice
man creates the most powerful artificial
intelligence of all time and immediately
uses it as an iPod shuffle mother takes
nearly 30 seconds for the title of the
goddamn movie to appear I'm all for
building suspense but if you're gonna
spend half a minute on something it
better be at least visually interesting
and not information we already know
because it's printed on our freaking
ticket reading also there are over seven
years away from their destination which
means any minute now Chris Pratt's gonna
wake up and make a morally questionable
decision
why does Walter need a hoodie I'm
assuming it doesn't get cold do ai's go
through an Eminem stage see the real
Slim Shady deploying energy recharge
sales now I think it's great they
brought back Fassbender for this role
since he was the best part of hermie
theist but if we're gonna change
something in the new model to keep
people from being disturbed well I
changed just the accent to sound like
he's from Venice Beach and is about to
catch some sick waves bro damn this ship
is cool I'm removing once in for this
awesome kingship which is really awesome
mother will track the energy sales
really mother needs to be told this how
can the AI in the synthetics exist to
such an advanced degree but you can't
put enough common-sense in a ship's AI
to immediately retract the sails when
mother dullard detects an oncoming storm
the James Franco cameo in this movie is
shorter than the one in dawn of the
Planet of the Apes why can't they get
this thing open again I know you're got
to keep these crowd sleep chambers
tighten all they have any specific tool
for this and it doesn't work it's it's
how he would have wanted to go Oh
everything sure seems to be working just
swimmingly on the ship that just
sustained a systemic disaster I mean all
Walter was shown doing is putting out a
fire at the control panel James Franco
was short on time so he just sent Ridley
Scott some b-roll from the set of 127
hours also seriously why is even in this
movie and don't tell me about the web
short film prequel nonsense I didn't
even do homework when I needed it to
pass my college courses I'm certainly
not doing it to better comprehend
alien prequel nonsense live up to Jacob
suit examples is mine example Jacob
again alright the Franco flambe ya never
knew it it was a random localized event
sir there's no way to detect spontaneous
telling flyers until it's too late and
also convenient to the plot it just lost
47 colonists and our captain we need
technology sergeant lope when dr.
Manhattan literally acknowledged this
like a minute ago also what they should
be acknowledging is that they woke up
seven years too early on this journey
and there's no way they'd have enough
food or utilities to last that long
considering everyone was supposed to be
in Crowley why the hell are these
monitors running screen savers instead
of displaying vital information that's
easy to see how the hell does Daniels
know this by tugging on one chain and
she's way away from the tiny computer
that actually gives the percentage maybe
she's an Android they disobeyed a direct
order she buried her husband actually no
he shot his ass into space even though
there should be like a million things to
do to repair the ship before taking a
shot of Jack and opening an airlock that
said I can't get a handle on this guy
does he really upset that they had a
brief funeral for their dead captain how
self-absorbed you have to be that your
crew is going through real trauma and
only you can think about is how it
reflects on you and they don't trust me
for the same reason the company didn't
trust me to lead this mission because
you can't be a person of faith and be
counted on to make qualified rational
decisions nevertheless the company did
put you second in command which given
the captain's tendency de camión showed
a lot of trust I don't care if they have
those little air booster thingies these
assholes go off for a space walk with no
tethers whatsoever Jesus didn't they see
gravity a rogue transmission most
probably your helmet must have picked it
up because you were so far out past our
communication buffers communication
buffers and that'd be an echo thank you
mister miss took a lot of damage been
happening every 46 seconds ever since we
got here but I neglected to mention this
incredibly specific detail until just
now it's beyond your most optimistic
projections for guy six how did we miss
this I scan the entire sector this
question will never be answered
square in a habitable zone how far they
said she's close
a little jump a few weeks you know I
said this in the aliens video space is
really really big so the fact that these
assholes wake up right next to a
habitable planet is such an
impossibility it couldn't even be
considered as a movie coincidence and
how long is it gonna take to get to
Oregon
seven years four months I think it's
safe to say that none of us are too keen
on getting back into one of those pods
at least for most of this movie's
runtime at the end we'll be totally okay
with it
all so here's the problem with the movie
her name is Daniels nothing else we
don't know anything about her backstory
other than she was married to the
captain and she wants to build a cabin
on a lake we don't even know her first
name that's why this movie is much more
Prometheus that it is alien oh listen to
this witty banter between this couple
that we barely know and that will surely
die early in this movie no masks really
I get that you know the air is
breathable but maybe just a bit of
precaution would be nice
remember kids just because you can
breathe something doesn't mean you
should also not only other I know
helmets everyone is required to wear
these ridiculous looking hats what does
the functionality of the earflaps damn
it why did Maggie decide to land in the
water when there's perfectly good land
right next to the spot she chose signal
source to say kilometers west which we
could have easily flown to or at least
over before we landed I have a still
hand signal sergeant lope we're all
right here
we can hear you feel free to use your
words and we might have a spot for our
colony right here Aurum was immediately
flying for premature celebration after
this conversation Network stay with
Corinne god dammit why must every alien
movie have to devolve into we should
split up shenanigans
other than just start the xenomorph
attacks you're an Alien movie not a teen
slasher flick feel free to alien so what
exactly is the outreach strategy for
crew recruitment for these things are
you the kind of person who's willing to
sneak a smoke break on an unknown planet
while paying zero attention to any alien
plant life you might be trampling around
you have we got a colonizing mission for
you
nobody has ears this clean I mean nobody
I swear just the other day Indiana Jones
came diving out of my ear canal the wax
boulder that fell out was so big what is
it about alien landscapes that make
people wanna poke and put their faces in
them I'm basically watching Prometheus
again with the little couples retreat
thrown in also something definitely
sprayed out of there so allow me to not
only keep my face in close proximity but
also not even mention it to anyone else
because I'm a space explorer dr.
Elizabeth Shaw
she was chief science officer of the
prometheus ship that disappeared
precisely 10 years ago
um someone left the synthetic and
exposition mode again oh sure
sure let's give everyone a photographic
cameo in this movie they get a light on
this
how does no one in this exploratory team
have any kind of room illumination with
them a flair anything just classic
headlamps that coal miners have been
using since the beginning of time why
does this future not feel like the
future I guess the tide came in over the
last 20 seconds because when Maggie left
the lander she was on dry land perhaps
we could have included that in the
curriculum for any human traveling on to
another planet science first touchy
touchy later does it still count as a
deus ex machina if it's the vicious
killer alien that's saved in a
ridiculous coincidental moment either
way I'm sitting that Three Stooges style
plasma plummet look I know that's a
quick little bastard this is pointing
blank guess the Covenant crew all went
to the esteemed stormtrooper school of
aiming the Leo morph runs like he works
for pythons Ministry of Silly Walks also
what the hell man the Neo morph that
came out of lead word immediately
attacked Quran in the Med pod but this
one just pieces out to find his buddies
well there's nothing you can do there's
nothing okay
I don't think lope needs to be told this
I mean love is strong at all but the man
just saw his love give birth to a pointy
rage baby so I think he knows what the
score is how is it possible that the
special effects in an alien movie in
2017 or at least 45% worse than the ones
in 1979 even though this alien kicked
Walters ass two seconds ago he'll slowly
creep up on Daniels in a useless attempt
to make the scene in suspense for sure
it must be nice to hear a humanist voice
on this planet and they don't have a lot
of option but these assholes blindly
follow David with no information
whatsoever other than the hundreds of
horribly burned bodies that adorn his
front yard also no one even thinks to
say something to this dude was a long
fucking hike out here so that was plenty
of time to say hey man what's your name
or what's up with the fucking dead
bodies out here also cuz up with the
fast benders and the hoodies in this
movie does David really need to make his
dramatic reveal later considering only
Walter will recognize him the most
nonsensical part of David being here
besides being a literal day of sex mark
and a few minutes ago is his Iggy Pop
impression also does nobody recognize
the resemblance between Walter and David
I mean I know the crews scared no but no
one even casually mentions that they're
the exact same person is there a safe
way to answer
this is your first question for the
human-like dude on a completely alien
planet
forced fast bonding it doesn't make
sense
suddenly it's apparent Daniels would be
excellent cinemasins wait mom I know
David has a flair for the dramatic but
he's still looking Android right which
means he could and should just give a
straight King answer to this very simple
question lucius malfoy here is totally
alone instead of being constantly
swarmed by the Covenant crew that
definitely has millions of questions
about the planet and the aliens David is
able to give himself a perfect haircut
using only garden shears and a blurry a
smear watch me I'll do the fingering no
way man the last time I heard this I got
in a lot of trouble with the wife movie
wastes runtime and movie magic in order
to show us Michael Fassbender playing
with himself oh yeah I remember
Aurum said something about faith about
45 minutes ago so were you planning on
developing that plotline metaphor theme
at all no caught my watch mighty
famous poet inadvertently writes the
mission statement for cinemasins wait
how is he sending down these virus vials
telekinesis levitation I mean that's a
Magneto's going on right there these
movies ever explain the black liquid and
why the engineers made it why couldn't
this movie have been from David's
perspective if you told me the answer to
all these things is another movie I will
know more myself through your skull
movie thinks that surprises are better
than the way better story they're
refusing to tell boys sure glad David
came up here to show the audience the
flashback to the engineer apocalypse
even though Walter just had to listen to
him ramble through a poem have you ever
dreamt about far-off worlds and thought
I'd love to soak my open wounds in the
water there without knowing the
slightest bit about what's in it well
sign up today for our next expedition
and soak away rather than keeping the
element of surprise and attacking her
from behind this alien prefers to take
his time and be a jump scaring dick also
the digital effects in this movie are
suddenly giving me a whole new
appreciation of I am Legend
no one hears this the bathroom isn't
that far away mother they're in trouble
you heard that you didn't leave us to be
safe this is the Bulls bull the ball the
Bulls in this movie the ship has 2,000
motherfucking innocent colonists on it
but this asshole has such a dynamic
boner for his dead wife that he's gonna
put everyone in jeopardy
one sin off for Fassbender's incredible
performance here some of the most
chilling stuff in the film heart and
soul Trump's blood and guts
every time Daniels makes Tennessee leave
the pilot's chair in the middle of
flying through in catastrophic geo storm
just to tell him that his wife's dead
have this movie come this is what I
wanted to show you my successes yes yes
please follow the creepy mad scientist
robot dude down into a dark cave
whatever could go wrong are they alive
waiting ring what I don't know but I bet
the best option is to walk right up on
them and see what's up honestly by this
point or imbeds this well I guess you
gotta play the hits
this ass David bioengineered these neo
morphs to be completely subservient to
only him directly from birth because all
these usually do is look for something
to kill and run away as soon as they're
born first off David lifts this out for
everyone to see second off isn't
everyone rushing around trying to get to
the extraction point but Walter is just
wandering around the compound looking
for existential clues about David's
crossbreeding fetish character and movie
plays the franchise's theme music as the
movie crumbles in on its own spiraling
self referential black hole such a
disappointment to me with this pity
one-liner after killing a fool Michael
Fassbender officially submits his
application to play James Bond ah that's
the stuff
it wouldn't be an alien movie if it
didn't show some of that sweet milky
Android juice going downstairs
careful god damn it stop splitting up
Tennessee is literally on the way to
rescue them right now but everyone on
the team split up as far as humanly
possible before his arrival now that
Daniels not hear any of that killing
going on in the other room exactly so
recite pretentious poetry to her until
she begs to be experimented on just so
you'll stop got it
there's been a few updates since your
day what's a fing n we get a late movie
scene of superhuman entities repeatedly
punching each other I guess at this
point everyone's saying becomes let's
just yell seven heaven Oh Dylan that is
clearly beaten causes good guy to pause
while reaching for a nearby hit and
weapon cliche moody tries to hold out on
showing us the winner of the ultimate
fast kicking stone is in the air and
knife being reached for and you cut away
to set up a later surprise movie is a
rock tease the motto of this crew is
everyone left behind also wait I thought
Tennessee said mother's saying those
storms out last summer eight or nine
hours and since then all they've done is
get ready to leave and split up a bunch
to explore which would not have taken
eight to nine hours even so we've got
perfect weather out here now also how
the long does it take Tennessee to get
here I know he's in a different Lander
but took Maggie a matter of seconds to
get to the planet's surface we're men to
believe this is Walter and not David and
he even has the same slash on the left
side of his face but no one else from
the crew saw
/ on his face besides David so he did
that to himself solely for the audience
okay we know the fight between Walter
and David lasted right up until Daniel's
and lope left the compound though that
means David had time to change his hair
color steal Walters clothes / himself in
the face and lop his hand off before
joining them which I mean come on movie
thanks movie one last reminder that
James Franco could have been in this
screw you even look good
geez Tennessee too soon man too soon
please report to the medbay why mother
there is an unidentified life-form on
the ship mother essentially plays the
pronoun game to get Daniels to go down
to the mid Bay with zero clear what it's
about be dead between X 3 & 4 Jesus this
newborn xenomorph somehow knows the
blueprints of this ship perfectly enough
to go immediately to the naked people is
this thing fully-grown already
considering this as a legacy movie a
fourth must have gotten a scholarship to
the Prometheus school of backing away
from things Walter where is it
Daniels this way or you could wait for
Walter to answer who would know the
exact location a lot of things just
happened there the alien was somehow
trapped for a while in a truck they open
a door to space and yet nothing was
really sucked out the alien had such a
killing boner that it looked back toward
the ship and Daniels not only knew the
exact time to duck so that the alien
would be killed she avoided all that
acid blood being spewed out of it and
all of that is more believable to me
than Danny McBride surviving this entire
movie know also why did David posing as
Walter go through all the trouble of
helping them kill the alien on the ship
only to then surprise surprise I'm evil
all along you did you meet them for any
reason he was able to command the ship
with his own voice so he didn't even
need Daniel's and definitely not
Tennessee wait there was also time for
David to swallow a couple of embryos
before he left he must be desperate to
make another one of these movies
dick yeah take a look out of starboard
oh my god it looks like a huge you know
how to whistle don't you Steve you just
put your lips together and hello
you built these weapons to destroy us
why
[Music]
because you are afraid of our gifts Oh
Gert uh-huh okay I am your father
where'd it come from
appears to be a main-sequence star not
like our own but all very old this
forest is old very old as your second I
need to protest officially
oh wow spenders they've rejected have
fun storming the castle
think it'll like if it'd take a miracle